ai systems and you've spoken extensively
how ai systems
manipulate you within social networks
and that's the biggest the biggest
problem isn't necessarily that um
there's advertisement that uh
you know social networks present you
with advertisements that then get you to
buy stuff that's not the biggest problem
the biggest problem is they then
manipulate you
you're they alter like your
human nature to get you to buy stuff or
or to get you to um
do whatever the advertiser wants
or maybe you can correct yeah i i don't
see it quite that way but we can work
with that as an approximation sure so my
i think the actual thing is even sort of
more ridiculous and stupider than that
but that's that's okay let's let's so my
question is
let's not use the word ai
uh but
how do we fix it
oh fixing social media um
that diverts us into this whole other
field in my view which is economics
which i always thought was really boring
but we have no choice but to turn into
economists if we want to fix this
problem because it's all about
incentives but um
i've been around this thing since it
started and and
i've been in the meetings where the
social media companies
sell themselves to the people who put
the most money into them which are
usually the big advertising holding
companies and whatnot and there's this
there's this idea that i think is kind
of a fiction
and maybe it's even
been recognized as that by everybody
that
the the algorithm will get really good
at getting people to buy something
because i think people have looked at
their returns and looked at what happens
and everybody recognizes it's not
exactly right
it's more
like a cognitive access
blackmail payment at this point
like you just to be connected you're
paying the money it's not so much that
the persuasion algorithms that so
stanford renamed its program but it used
to be called engage persuade the engage
part works the persuade part is iffy but
the thing is that
once people are engaged in order for you
to exist as a business in order for you
to be known at all you have to put money
in oh that's dark
oh no that doesn't work but they have to
but they're still it's a it's a giant
it's a giant cognitive access blackmail
scheme at this point
so um because the science behind the
persuade part it's not entirely
it's not entirely uh a failure but it's
it's not what the the there's we play
make believe that it it works more than
it does um the damage doesn't come
honestly
as i've i've said in my books i'm not
anti-advertising i actually think
advertising can be demeaning and
annoying and banal
and ridiculous
and take up a lot of our time with
stupid stuff like there's a lot of ways
to criticize that
advertising that's
accurate and it can also lie and all
kinds of things however
if i look at the biggest picture i think
advertising at least as it was
understood before social media helped
bring people into modernity in a way
that overall
actually did benefit people overall
and
you might say am i contradicting myself
because i was saying you shouldn't
manipulate people yeah i am probably
here i mean i'm not i'm not pretending
to have this perfect airtight
world view without some contradictions i
think there's a bit of a contradiction
there so you know we're looking at the
long arc of history advertisement has as
in some parts benefited society yeah
because it funded some efforts that
perhaps yeah i i mean i think like
there's a there's the thing where uh
sometimes i think it's actually been of
some years
now
let's
where the damage comes is a different
thing though social media
algorithms on social media have to work
on feedback loops where they present you
with stimulus they have to see if you
respond to the stimulus now the the
problem is that the the measurement
mechanism for telling if you respond in
the engagement
feedback loop is very very crude it's
things like whether you click more or
occasionally if you're staring at the
screen more if there's a forward-facing
camera that's activated but typically
there isn't
so you have this incredibly crude back
channel of information
and so it's crude enough that it only
catches
sort of the more dramatic
responses from you and those are the
fight-or-flight responses those are the
things where you get scared or pissed
off or aggressive
or horny you know these are these
ancient the sort of what are sometimes
called the lizard brain circuits or
whatever you know these these fast
response old old old evolutionary
business
circuits that we have that um are
helpful in survival once in a while but
are not us at our best they're not who
we want to be they're not how we relate
to each other they're this old business
but it's so then just when you're
engaged using those intrinsically
totally aside from whatever the topic is
you start to get incrementally just a
little bit more paranoid xenophobic
aggressive
you know you get a little stupid and
like you become a jerk
and it happens slowly it happens it's
not it's not like everybody's like
instantly transformed but it does kind
of happen progressively where people who
get hooked kind of get drawn more and
more into this pattern of being at their
worst would you say that people are able
to when they get hooked in this way look
back at themselves from 30 days ago
and say
i am less happy
with who i am now or i'm not happy with
who i am now versus who i was 30 days
ago are they able to self-reflect when
you take yourself outside of the lizard
brain sometimes um i wrote a book about
people suggesting people take a break
from their social media to see what
happens and maybe even well it was
actually the title of the book was just
the arguments to delete your account
yeah
arguments 10 arguments although i always
said i don't know that you should i can
give you the arguments it's up to you
i'm always very clear about that but you
know i get like i don't have a social
media account obviously and
it's not that easy for people to reach
me they have to search out an
old-fashioned email address on a super
crappy antiquated website like it's
actually a bit i don't make it easy and
even with that i get this huge flood of
mail from people who say oh i quit my
social media i'm doing so much better i
can't believe how bad it was
but the thing is what's for me a huge
flood of mail would be an imperceptible
trickle from the perspective of facebook
right and so uh i think it's rare for
somebody to look at themselves and say
oh boy i sure screwed myself over
well it's a really hard thing to ask if
somebody none of us find that easy right
you